ltd ragazzi mi vedete questo video sono
fa vj oggi se dio vuole
ma dio non verrà e questo dio si chiama
pietro finiremo mai kraft parkour che
siamo arrivati a più o meno aspetta che
vedere quanto siamo arrivati io vedo già
gli alberi quindi in teoria manca solo
un giro
manca solo un giro di eco sapevo che
mentre il mentre tentavo di sporgere lo
sapevo lo finiremo subito
va bè ragazzi ne va avanti perché manca
veramente poco o non possiamo non
finirlo se mi tocchi ti uccido vedo già
dello slide per terra solo divertente ma
tu hai fatto a esaltando grazie
ma c'è un buco qui previsto no c'è un
braccio un rogo
c'è un buco e bay nelle cose vieni
questa roba è a posto
no no no ad amazon o dai veramente
finiamolo stavolta che sogna cacao
spiega mi aspetta cosa vuol dire solo è
mai difficilissima no no aspetto che
cosa ho capito no non penso tu debba
fare così sai vicino mi sa di no
sino a vivere qua stati superati
diamante e portare due più slancio a
questo però mai quelli ok come hai fatto
a cadere scusa impossibile per molti
bravo carico ci provo ci provo sì grande
ma perché io sono completi co eh sì
perché non salto sono salto poetico
anche non mondo non lo so salta tu non
lo so cosa ho detto va bene va bene vai
vai prova c è di che un po è vero però
aspetta
ciao poverino dai ce l'ho fatta te lo
giuro non so
esatto qua c'è un passaggio occhio che
fanno ste cose strane non si capisce in
due se la persona plate che può aprire
quello nessuno ti ritieni su quello che
ne so
ok perfetto è una volta qua non so non
so vedo come fatto è perché c'è una
semplice i poteri in sei un mago come si
fa a fare sta roba quali vi salta ho
capito no aspetta non so se ho capito
che si può fare si può fare prova però
da lì poi dovrai scusa la sopra al fungo
il fungo rosso al fungo rosso secondo me
non si può fare proveniamo
no è vero social fatto ci ho fatto ci ho
fatto a quadri arrivare all'albero ma
siete scemi amico aspetta che dovrò fare
sta roba
questo è fatto è fatto però non so da
quanto devo andare a o che ho capito ma
poi tutto questo bordello per salire su
delle staccionate il minuscole ma ti
pare
per questo da fastidio come cosa è se
vieni per una volta arrivato qua infatti
a e se c'è una data a testa vabbè
affetto il vino e non c'è il coso però
non ci apprezzano e va bene c'è uno
slide quami corretta vieni vieni vieni
vieni porta come si fa qua è salvo ecco
perfetto ora questo mette qualcosa
d'interessante tipo è ma come come fai a
non è che devi tornare indietro e
ritornare indietro con tricarico ok e mi
chiese se cadi quali fai tutto no per
l'online pirla no non so nemmeno come a
ok ma se come se faccio solo slime ci
arrivò direttamente sai bene
insomma boves come trovare
guardai cielo creduto tantissimo
ok ok vai vai tu bravissimo suo forte
grazie grazie anch'io sono fortissimi
lorca vacca e vai avanti la pratica
pressure dove l'ha presa bene però non è
vero cavalcavia tra lo ha fatto prima
forza roba che fenomeno tensione ok è ma
come arriva la fine amico ci sei
eccoti dimmi dove deve arrivare pozzo
qua tu sei qui si saltare qui sopra
secondo me no però ci provo io credo al
cuore tuo ci credo forte mai fatto il
cicr è detto sorpreso perché è
sicuramente non la vedo dura non lo vedo
bravo prego amico era la non ha trovato
lo giuro forse non mettono più presso il
play perché alla fine forse no non è
vero se per ma no no no no speriamo di
no perché ti può amore di porti dall
inizio allora li c'e una roba che c'è
una roba sicuramente bisogna saltare
sulle mie amiche mi che minchia
bravissimo bravissima cantante è lo so
se cadete quali porti dal mit
praticamente è quello il problema di
dove trovare una maglietta presso della
rai porc ce l'ho fatta allora aspetta
che da qua può essere difficile ma
eccolo number one
ma perché ma è difficilissimo non so
come ho fatto te lo giuro qua è
veramente un bordeaux che ce l'ho fatta
qui era ora vieni qua no saltino
nuovamente facile perfetto ok e mo
avviare
pjanic è perfetto e dopo mi aspetti ma
muori ok e da qua dove devo andare
scusami eh vabbè le cose difficilissime
qua
continuano è un macello svetta ok però
l'acqua scusami come dovrei mai fare in
basso rdo gesù si pensi u purt aspettata
la donna grazia
no sono scemo scemo sassolini magagna e
da qua è un macello rega come come ma
scusami dio non ci credo grazie
sì c'è poi salta pure di asma e prociv
la tensione è già lì bravo ci hanno
creduto per un attimo ci ho creduto
vaibus difficile suicidi t ma cosa avete
fatto questo no no no è simile aspetta
adesso si fa tutti in tre secondi tonico
iocco guardano pescare qua e magari
scusa poi dopo ha speso doveva stare con
un po le cose presto
ok sono ok a posto avevo visto
fantastico sembrava un mix di orgasmi
sto video attenzione perfetto e mo cos'è
quella roba lì è fatta sì sì mi guarda
lo guarda lo amen
guardalo libro gaming signori
mammamia oggi così fenomeno fenomeni si
caduto si rifà daccapo sì però si non
chiedermi come massima episodio ho fatto
anche il pezzo doppio telo già oggi non
solo da ciò oggi si finisce sto gioco
lo dico io non lo so ragazzi dobbiamo
andare quando c'è una scala quasi una
scarsa una scala una scarpa non si
riesce a passare questa mi sembra un po
incasinata del solito
ok sono già notte qui c'è un quadro come
fatto tutto questo per noi fanno le
cantine ma non c'è niente l'ora come
fatto a seguirli ma non c'è chi pur
nella stanza piccolissima ma no c'è un
posto segreto si porta al rigore
visibili solo prima ora ok ti sera su ok
aveva aspetta che provare anch'io
ok da poi scusa come hai fatto a dietro
il quadro a figata
ma se penso che si potesse fare sta roba
ah ok ok pc di quanto pensassi ok ha
detto eh sì l'ho detto rega ok tensione
la number one viene mi sono mio meglio
provaci provaci bravissima è troppo
corto no ad aspettare ok guarda forse ti
salvo che ti prendo il preso il play
tokay andata bene oggi va suicidi di
suoi cbt ok ora guarda guarda guarda
quanto manca alla fine guarda lì ci
siamo siamo proprio noi ci siamo ci
siamo è lì per niente dobbiamo saltare
solo tra questi due alberi tensione in
questa difficile regalo siamo arrivati
veramente ad un passo dalla fine non
possiamo arrenderci adesso qualche ristò
facendo così incredibile bravissimo ho
mai fatto vorrei mi sa che non devi fare
così è già provato a farlo
attenzione aspetto capito no ok
difficilissima sta roba da giuro ok ho
fatto bravo ok da lì adesso provate
andare sul anche se non penso ci siano
presso il plate dopo va ai proci bove
elise lo slime devo andare
bravissimo dottore anche visto come
invece c'è una presso plate
no e allora aveva anche ci prova poi mi
spieghi cosa che cosa vedi
guarda ho sbattuto la testa ma ce l'ho
fatta lo stesso che culo incredibile vai
o qua devi arrivare sopra l'albero
immagino che se non ho ancora visto cosa
devi fare
perfetto sono già qua no basta e la fina
mi confine dove alla fine vedo vedo la
fine
te lo giuro non è vero che sarà il mondo
ma sei una persona inutile all'essere
umano dai ma sei stupido nella vita non
è vero ma figli di tua madre lercia
putrida u6 provaci amico meno male non
sia arrivato ti avrei solo ucciso a e
buttati che presto il play presa si è
bravo bravissimo nori mai detto amico
gli ultimi due cose e abbiamo finito
attenzione non è vero non è possibile
l'ultimo sbagliato continua salto lo
sbagliato ok ok amico o l'ultimo salto
da fare
vieni qua lo facciamo insieme profiliamo
insieme se vieni stavo scherzando
no no no no non è vero non ero voleva
saltare in tempo prima di buttarsi
maglie fastidio dai lo faccio da solo
sfiga no sono caduto non riesco a farlo
da futuro sia arrivata all'ultimo salto
non riesco a farlo perché la non può
arrivare primato mi rifiuto no vat
aspetto una brava persona spero ti
aspetto ok che mai dai tre 21 mag chiama
baseball the king tr ragazzi ieri chi
sono i rack tutti e due
approdo del re riga ce l'abbiamo fatta
cioè io adesso 26 episodi quanti episodi
5 ott non so ma non siamo arrivati in
centro
non c'entro cinque episodi per prego
prego prego grazie a te di averci fatto
fare le views ei limoni e per avermi
fatto passare del tempo con il mio
migliore amico pietro non ci ha creduto
a stava bene grazie sì sì va bene
capodanno è tornato a cui grazie e
niente oggi scaliamo le montagne
explaining è fatto benissimo ragazzi
spero che questa serie vi sia piaciuto
ci abbiamo messo un botto arrivare in
cima ma ce l'abbiamo fatta
ci sono altre mappe parkour che
sicuramente andremo a fare e tra l'altro
semele consigliate nei commenti noi ci
guardiamo le migliori e la migliore in
assoluto la scegliamo e magari la
portiamo come seconda serie insomma
magari non così difficile grazie no
vabbè la difficoltà e ci stava dai non è
non era così ma si ci stava non era così
male quindi ragazzi spero che questa
serie vi sia piaciuta cosa è servito da
serie servito vi è piaciuto come ti
piace anche ai social torna descrizione
cesari fiscale e vediamo alla prossima
vita
beh ragazzi che non c'è il telecomando
però vabbè ho dimenticato sotto dove
scendere di risalire da ragazzi
[Musica]